歡迎收看理財達人秀
最愛開車的教學單元
歌有仇必報
好 我們都要先上景語喔
本內容可能會有一些
露骨的言語
如果引發不適的話
就盡情轉台
喜歡的就留下來看
其實我們觀看長度還滿長的
長度滿長的
顯見喜歡的人還滿多的
景語1
景語2是什麼
這一節內容
是屬於比較短的唷
比較短
在操作面上可能是幾天就會結束的
所以喜歡短進短出的觀眾朋友
很適合看這一集
如果是長線投資的
可能這一集就比較不適用
但我覺得會喜歡你的
應該都是短的吧
對啊 因為本人時間短
我們要講清楚好不好
什麼叫本人短 感覺還怪怪的
時間比較短一點
拼周轉綠的啦
拼周轉綠的
要service很多檔
對 很多檔
每一檔都要臨信他一下
拼周轉綠的
就跟古代的皇帝一樣
你不能天天翻同一個牌子
每天翻不同牌子
那假如牌子表現特別好的話
像今年的長榮
本人還臨信了他三天
連續三晚
連續三晚 四天三夜
弄到快虛脫才舒坦
因為長榮今年真的是太好了 太棒了
我們今天要交的是
因為我們都知道除泉洗
今年的行情不錯唷
很多都是除完洗的隔天就拉高
很多這樣
那如果用小錢來賭一下
好像也不賴
對啊 你可以用泉鎮來賭啦
對
也可以用期貨賭
就不大適合用現股
為什麼
今年很多現股也是除息當天就拉高
因為長榮的現股它的配息配太多了
除非你的稅率很低
稅率腳是不用繳稅或者是5%的
那你用這個現股來做還可以
那你的稅率腳高的話
其實你的成本很重
像長榮有很多大戶可能30%還是40%的稅
光長榮一檔
他的稅交繳20塊
剛好就他除息
兩根的錢
所以他漲了兩根
他賺來的錢就拿去繳稅
所以其實他得用
其他的金融商品來做
等於全證跟個股期
在稅率上面是很好的一個工具
對 真的很好
所以要先理解他有槓桿風險
但他有其他的優點
小哥三晚都不睡
表現好 買了隔音就漲停啊
漲停都來不及賣完耶
因為我前一天都是499
49我下去買
小哥嗨了三天
買499我還PO
因為我還不曉得隔音怎麼樣
我還想說499買太多
因為造勢造太好了
我發現當前一天造勢還造不錯
我就499買一買買了快一萬張全證
一萬張全證喔
買到1萬張也真的是厲害
對啊 每檔就買個2、3千張
不是全鎮小哥 全鎮大哥
買到1萬張 結果隔天賣不完
賣不完就漲停了
在隔天賣不完又漲停了
所以我弄了3、4天才賣完
報酬率還不錯啦
那我們現在講一下除全息
到底為什麼用全鎮可以賺到除全息行情
先聊一下
好 那我們現在講 基本的
第一個除全是發股票
發股票給你
那除息發現金
那除菲息稅費 除菲息要繳中二所得稅
二代健保補充費
所以這種看起來
對高所得而言 它成本蠻重的
所以長榮就很多人有氣息的賣壓
你想想看光佩息 它繳20塊
不如賣掉再買回來
所以你看它在除菲前一天走勢軟趴趴
除菲隔天立馬漲停
因為不如賣掉再買回來
因為它繳的稅實在太重了
那為什麼除了一期當天股價容易上漲
第一個
這個大五東為了避稅先賣股票
賣了再買回來都划算啦
第二個呢
股價看起來變便宜
長榮出一期155
隔天平盤價剩85
你看差那麼多
那我會155買不起
85看起來好便宜喔
所以隔天就漲錢了
第三個蠻好玩的
有人不知道今天除息這個有常聽你在講對 一直掛價每奇怪了怎麼今天除息也不知道所以呢會用昨天收盤價掛買金
像長榮是沒辦法用昨天收盤價
離太遠了
但是有些配的少
你可以用昨天收盤價掛買金
一買還以為掛低買到
事實上是掛高買到
那這種就很容易導致
當天股價容易上漲
至少開高
通常我們春行就是玩開高而已
只要開高我就賣了
後面我們就留給古魚去玩
古魚你不要這樣講他
古魚前後都玩
前後都玩
他玩的可多了
他玩好幾年
我們玩前面就好
古魚他可以前後都玩
因為他們有的
例如說像之前說金融股有的
除夕完變得便宜嘛
他們就會開始佈具
我們金融果都是開告我們就賣了
希望他來接手
古瑜是我的好朋友
你們兩個真的很好耶
他去日本你還幫他送行
還跟他講說
哎呦 輪到你去日本了
他還去夾娃娃
我用送行兩個字怪怪的
你還跟他就是說Hello
那我們佈局除緣期的行情重點
第一個要懂選
怎麼選
通常第一個我們會挑高殖利率股票
因為越高殖利率的
這個股價隔天看起來越便宜
例如說殖利率7%
股價隔天就打93折
平盤價打93折
殖利率10%就打9折
所以通常挑高殖利股票
那有PayRA股票鼓勵就更好啦
就更好啦
那找開盤價打折高的股票
就開盤的平盤參考價
我們講是頻繁參考價
按照統計數據
我們會去找過去初選席
開高機率比較高的個股
這個其實我們之前有一集有教過
可以撈得出來的
開高機率高
那當然今年開高機率可能也比較高
不過這也沒有一定
那懂做的話呢
我們可以利用股票期貨跟全證來參與
因為你總不能每次都用股票參與
你每次都用股票參與
哇 你的稅金會很多
因為你每次參與
你就一直領到鼓勵所得
你的所得稅急距可能從5% 12%
20% 30% 40% 就會變很多
那等到你的股票所得稅急距高的話
鼓勵所得急距高的話
你記得你要選28%的
這個系統會自動幫你選
自動幫你結稅
那你也可以去找充滿好的股票
萬一你怕參與籌碼
你又怕下跌的話
至少籌碼好的股票
比較有機會漲
你可以這樣子看
這種我們都會找主力5日籌碼集中度大於5%
或者主力有連續買的
主力有連續買你就可以提早佈局
因為除選席真的還蠻多人在玩的
有時候太多人玩
會在除選席的前一天見到高點
太多玩了 像今年的陽基工程
除了以前大家拼命玩 你知道嗎
你不講 我還不知道這一檔是什麼
你剛剛講陽 我也說 陽明在除息前有漲停
結果不是 陽基工程
陽基工程 就是冷門股
但是今年很多人玩你知道嗎
玩到後面我就知道
哇 陽基除了那一天一定開高走低
因為太多人買全鎮了
因為陽基它有配股
有配股會很多人玩
那很多人都提前買了 提前三天一天 兩天 提前一天
導致呢 陽機除全那一天
真的開高
那立馬往下殺 殺了一個大1K
全部的人都想到
全部的人都到貨
所以太多人玩了
你可以在前兩天買 然後呢
前一天假如有大漲 你也可以先賣一點啦
就賣掉算了喔
對啊 不然隔天還要跟大家擠著賣
擠著賣
那一天呢 我也是跟大家擠著賣
沒想到耶
還要跟大家擠
所以有時候不太喜歡教學
教學都教出敵人
你知道嗎 教育的敵人
因為大家都跟你做同樣的
跟你一起買一起賣
就變敵人了
其實教學真的是這樣
我們常發現大部分人其實有點學不起來
但只要中間有一兩個學起來
變厲害 那就變教育的敵人
生活上的好朋友
生活上的好朋友小哥你怎麼這麼佛心教我這麼多然後我來謝謝這樣子謝 變生活上好朋友 教一上敵人有時候跟他講說你不要跟我一起道好不好
跟你搶同一個女人 很煩
大家一起買一起賣
因為有時候我們還一起挑到同一檔權政你知道嗎
你看看你們 表兄弟就變多了
對啊 那我們動作慢的 變表弟
好啦 那我們初一期講快錢的操作心法
第一個 有配股題材的可以提早付出
配股的
因為大家都一起 大家喜歡找配股的啦
因為配股的股票打折大家比較多
會幫你生小孩
對對對
是真的啊 是真的
所以要提早做啦
不然不曉得小孩是誰的
欸 越來越講越歪了
好 來看第二個
金融股呢 前一天買就可以
為什麼他前天買就有個
人家也有配股啊
因為金融股呢
我們常常都看金融股就是前天有時候還在跌啊
所以不用太早買
那金融股常常都在雛息那天還蠻強的
金融股都很奇怪喔
因為他除完之後大家覺得變便宜啦
因為他很多股價都二三十而已嘛
對啊 甚至十幾塊
我會想
看起來很燙耶
也不是奇怪啦
因為我們有很多純股主的
對對對對
都鼓吹
金融股除息那天好好買
因為那天變便宜
因為有他們在
所以我們就有獲利的空間
好 第三個
不管有沒有賺錢
你假如在玩這種除全息的
全鎮除息當天你都得賣
你拚翻桌綠的
你不要這個
沒賺錢一直爆一直爆
那就不好
那我們再來看
除全息行情
個股的實際案例
我覺得我們一開始的景宇說得真好
那我們先看長榮
這個開盤價打折這個數字有點錯了
為什麼 因為我們從軟體抓的時候
已經沒辦法抓到當天的狀況
不過他打折真的打蠻多的
那開盒機率他也高啊
你看這邊有很多顆星
開盤價打折是沒打到那麼多
因為他今年配了70塊
所以他算是今年打折打最多的
他從155變成85
所以他算起來打折也是在打5折
打5折多
所以長榮我就買一堆
買一堆參與他的除息
來給各位看我的戰績啦
我們總數就不寫了
秀對照單
總數就不寫了
那你看我都買499的
後面券商照市照150回收
那我就150到給他
那這個就像是髮型還不錯啦
髮型對我還蠻不錯的
就是他也蠻公正的把
他收回去了
那你看報酬率很恐怖的
300多%
損益都是6位數的
所以加一加也蠻恐怖的啦
長龍我就買很多
因為我對他特別有信心
因為今年他的殖利率最高啦
還蠻不錯的
好 而且長榮的話
有很多人幫你做後面 不要擔心
對 後面一對買啊
對
所以我的全鎮報酬率才可以這麼好
好
這是用全鎮做長榮的除息
好 接下來我們看長榮的好兄弟楊明
楊明
楊明一樣 他開高機率也高
可是楊明在除息前就先拉高囉
就先拉了 那我在長榮大漲的時候
我也去買楊明
所以我在前兩天介入
好 你就知道要早一點去了
早點去 免得當表弟
陽明我就先買 前兩天買
結果前天這還漲停嘛
隔天除息 那天又漲停
那陽明除息完之後 我知道
因為去年的案例
就是因為除息配很多大漲的
還會再跌回來
因為他只是當時的事件而已
所以我在高檔除了把權政賣掉以外
我還去空期貨
因為我賭他會回來
那我們下一看陽明的戰績
陽明戰績就沒有長榮那麼漂亮
那我還是買法性
可能要找我代言
你看報酬率也蠻漂亮的
一兩百%
你不要和人家改規則
我跟你講
就還不錯啦
因為我就對這種造勢造得還不錯的法行商我們要表揚一下啦因為通常除夕那一天肇事都造得亂七八糟了都不大好了因為對他們而言 他們這個也蠻傷的
因為這個陽明跟長榮今年發言商是大賠的
因為他跳空開漲停
對他們而言很難避險
報酬率各位看 1-200%
也是賺很多六位數
所以長榮跟陽明
今年對我來講真的蠻補的
所以我也是航海王
你也是
航海小哥
其中一個
虧你當初還被人家說是航山
現在你要從航海往上賺回來
你不要
我們是靈活的好不好
航山我們也是在高檔跟你講
230塊
特別跳那天跟你講
還有就是公布鼓勵
公布鼓勵的時候
對啊 我們那時候也講
公布鼓勵你也是要小心
所以可多可空
這個就是我們的特色
我們不會單純只講多的
那怎麼用全證來參與除選期呢
我們記得在除選期前
我們要挑好全證買進
在賭隔天開購後出場
除選期前我們就要挑
X槓比低的
X槓比是價差比除以十字槓桿
X槓比我們之前有教學
大家用X槓比查一下
我們前面有一整集價X槓比
主要是X槓比低
那天數你就不用太記得去管它了
全證我們因為只參與一兩天
其他的就好券商
這影台波動率不要一直掉就好了
那全證用這個去參與這還不錯
反正你記得挑X槓比低
不要太價外 就沒什麼問題了
好 那我們來看一下
像這個節目播出的時候
已經除全息完了
像這個玉山金
玉山金 用軟體我們就可以看出
它差價比
那很考驗你耶
你現在講的對不對
播出的時候就要驗證
玉山金每年的配股都還不錯
每年的行情都還不錯
它都有配股票
都有配股票 每年都有配
所以玉山金已經連續七八年都開高了
開高還走高
那不是開高率跟大AK
因為玉山金要大AK
還沒有那麼容易
所以玉山金我們每年大概都會參與一下
所以這個挑這種來參與
這個除菸洗都還不錯
那各位記得這個參與除菸洗的時候
你一定要看一個東西啊
什麼東西
看隱含波動率
蛤這最難
我每次聽到隱含波動率我都會直接Fair out
隱含波動率就是要去算全證的合理價格會用到的
那隱含波動率呢 假如是平平的代表說這家造序造得很好
反而要平的
要平的 不能斜斜的
假如你遇到隱含波動率 假如沒有很穩定的
你就要小心一點
那這個還好啦 因為這個在28.5、27在那邊震盪的還好
那你假如看到從50然後掉到剩30的
那不行
垂垂的就很多人不喜歡
垂頭上氣的
垂頭上氣是不是
我還以為是潑垂垂的
不管潑垂垂的還是另外一個垂垂的
大家都不喜歡
反正只要影韓波動率一直往下的
那代表說這種權政造勢就沒有很好
所以這個是重點
只要權政它影韓波動率穩定
那基本上你就可以賺到你應該有的報酬
是 好
等於我們來看一下玉山經濟
有沒有辦法複製前面長榮陽明的走勢
對不對 沒有那麼強啦
但是他是每一年還滿穩定這樣子的
每一年至少開高一兩%常常見
那今年我也不知道會不會怎樣
因為到現在為止還沒出啊
播出的時候來減成照
只要跌了可以幫我減掉嗎
好 如果跌了我們就把預算金剪掉
好 那大家會說
我們在公開版講的好像都是已經發生的例子
有沒有最近要除全席
小哥也正在follow的
我知道 因為大家
我們雖然做了之前
例如說除席後開高的那一集
做了插槓筆什麼的
但大家回去學又很痛苦
所以龍耀班定起來好不好
龍耀班定起來
小哥會來告訴你有哪一些
最近要除全席
他已經準備用權政布局的標的